the topic that I want to talk about is
policy challenges for green economy and
sustainable economic development and
those of you who know from the the teep
course this talk is based on a paper
that I wrote recently for the UN journal
Natural Resources Forum which was kind
of a ex post reflection after having
done the global green New Deal project
that Pavan mentioned and the emphasis
here is on challenges for sure
and I want to elaborate in this talk on
the themes that I touch on on this paper
and in specific specifically well I want
to start off with this is it's a little
bit about what is a green economy mean
by a green economy and secondly what
progress has been made can we sit back
from the last few years which Pavan and
I have been involved in at the
international level trying to stimulate
some ideas on a green economy and get it
into policymaking circles have we made
progress not just us but as the world
made progress on attaining a green
economy I then want to go on and explain
that if we are going to continue to make
progress if we're going to be real about
their progress we need to overcome a
sustainability challenge and I'll
explain what that is and the second
challenge has to do with funding always
a dirty word in the international
community but something that really has
to be seriously addressed and then I
will make some final remarks as Papa
mentioned I'm an economist so much of
what I will talk about comes from an
economic perspective but I hope that you
will understand that from my perspective
as well that that economics is essential
to this whole argument so what is a
green economy well I think a good place
to start
with the definition by the UN
Environment Program that a green economy
is one that results in improved human
wellbeing and social equity while
significantly reducing environmental
risks and ecological scarcities and as
you'll see in this talk this definition
is key to understanding whether or not
we've made progress and what are the
challenges ahead just two can carry on
what this definition means as unep
elaborates is that we want to have an
economy that is essentially low-carbon
resource efficient and socially
inclusive now it doesn't mean that we
let go of conventional indicators of
economic progress such as income growth
employment and poverty alleviation but
such targets and goals should be driven
by investments that at the same time
reduce carbon emissions and pollution
enhance energy and resource efficiency
and prevent the loss of biodiversity and
ecosystem services so can we claim
progress towards a green economy well in
terms of the intellectual debate and at
least in terms of the conceptual
thinking on this I think it's it's fair
enough to say that green growth the
promotion of energy efficiency and clean
energy technologies and sustainable
development have been increasingly
viewed as complementary goals by the
International policymakers so these
items are on the agenda of the global
community particularly policymakers and
even during the height of the global
recession such as the 2010 Seoul summit
of g20 leaders as this quote shows the
the rhetoric is there policymakers have
been talking about these goals and
implementing these goals for some time
even at the height of the recession it
was argued that green growth is a
necessary objective so the summit leader
said we recognize that sustainable green
growth as is as it is inherently a part
of
Stanwell evelopment is a strategy of
quality development enabling countries
to leapfrog old technologies and many
sectors including through the use of
energy efficiency and clean technology
and so forth you can read the rest of it
and that suggests that at the forefront
of international policymaking is the
idea of making progress towards a green
economy now it's not just been rhetoric
either I think it's fair to say that one
of the unique things about what happened
during the Great Recession of 2008 or
nine is that many governments a handful
of governments and possibly a few more
included a sizeable green fiscal
component in their efforts to boost
aggregate demand and this had has never
been done before as part of a deliberate
global policy strategy there has never
been an effort to include major
environmental investments particularly
in a time of recession and crisis and
the type of green fiscal stimulus falls
into three categories there was of
course investments in energy efficiency
which included support for energy
conservation in buildings fuel efficient
vehicles public transport and rail and
improving electric grid transmission
there were investments targeted at
low-carbon power such as support for
renewable energy and carbon capture and
sequestration and then finally there's
been general investments in
environmental improvement and pollution
control particularly for waste and
pollution management and also water
improvements the amount of money was
reasonably sizeable of the three point
three trillion dollars allocated
worldwide for fiscal stimulus over two
thousand eight nine five hundred twenty
twenty-five hundred twenty two billion
was devoted to green expenditures or tax
breaks almost all of it was by g20
governments not all g20 governments but
certainly a large number
and this green spending amounts to about
16% of total fiscal stimulus and 0.7% of
world GDP not insignificant the most of
the money of the green stimulus about
three-fifths was or I saw or nearly
two-thirds was spent on energy
efficiency if you want to have a
breakdown here are the totals for global
spending on green stimulus in the major
country contributions you can see that
by far China the United States spent the
the largest in terms of absolute amount
of the over 500 billion dollars spent on
green stimulus when you look at greed
stimulus as a share of total fiscal
stimulus in the case of South Korea
almost the entire stimulus package was
consider what consisted of green
measures it was all so large in China
and surprisingly large in the European
Union although you have to understand
the amount spent by the European Union
on total fiscal stimulus was relatively
small the United States where we
received a lot of attention for our
green stimulus package really only 12%
of the total fiscal stimulus could be
described as green I think the most
interesting statistic is Green stimulus
as a share of GDP as I mentioned the
global average was 0.7 percent but when
you look at some of the Asian countries
particularly South Korea and China
you're talking about quite a sizeable
hunk of GDP five percent in the case of
South Korea over three percent in terms
of China Japan one percent Australia 1.3
percent the United States although again
absolutely large it was a small
relatively small share of GDP relative
to some Asian countries so these are
rather large commitments and you know
the big question is will these policies
be successful well there's two ways of
looking at the success
these policies one is did they actually
stimulate aggregate demand in the short
run but I think the more interesting
question to me is whether these policies
will be judged successful in terms of
getting major economies on a transition
path to more sustainable development and
particularly the green economy goals as
outlined by the UNEP definition I read
earlier HSBC Global Research forecasts
that the global market for clean energy
and energy efficiency will triple by
2020 and they cite the the the green
stimulus efforts that started during the
Great Recession as a major reason for
jump-starting these markets which could
be considered progress towards a green
economy and in particular they note the
HSBC global research notes that the
expansion will be led by low-carbon
vehicles such as plug-in hybrids and
full electric vehicles China's growing
clean energy market which was the focus
of their stimulus package and the need
for upfront capital for the new green
technologies as they start to
proliferate through the world but for a
lot of reasons which I won't go into
here in this talk but which I've written
about you have to appreciate that
relying on green stimulus stimulus alone
is not enough to instigate a global
green recovery or a transition to a
green economy for one and something I'll
talk a little bit later there's a lot of
complementary policies or the lack of
complementary policies that hold back
the long term effect for example fossil
fuel subsidies and other markets to
start distortions as well as the lack of
environmental pricing policies in
general including carbon markets and
regulation these will diminish the
impact of any of these 20 green simha
stimulants on long run investments and
job creation in green sectors in
addition there's likely to be trade
and many of these stimulus packages
between short-run and long-run throat
rent objectives and long-run growth of
environment and employment impacts and a
study by the World Bank written by John
strand and Mike Tolman illustrates this
with a number of programs whether its
energy efficiency or other clean energy
programs you can see that they have
variable impacts in terms of short-term
stimulus effects versus more long-term
growth greenhouse gas reduction and
environmental improvement effects so so
again if you focus on the short-term
aspects of these programs you may
sacrifice the long-term and vice-versa
and let's be clear the main purpose of
these packages was to find a series of
policies to stimulate aggregate demand
in the short run during the recession so
perhaps by doing so particularly by the
focus on energy efficiency in particular
many of these green stimulus packages
you may not have quite the bang in terms
of long term transitions to more
environmental or green economy okay now
that's that's my in the nutshell
assessment of what actually has happened
and and and the issue of progress but I
think there's a more fundamental problem
and challenge here that's been neglected
by the international community and
policymakers and I think it's this that
it's good to have rapid expansion of
clean energy in energy efficiency
markets that's great and that should be
a boost to global green growth in some
way but it still does not guarantee that
the world will attain sustainable
development investments in clean energy
energy efficiency are good and maybe
necessary is part of a more sustainable
or green economy but they're not
sufficient and the reason is what's
neglected in this picture if you go back
to that unit definition is the problem
of ecological scarce
green growth in the form of green more
expansion of clean energy and energy
efficiency does not mean sustainable
growth as long as global ecosystem
degradation continues to be a major
problem on one generating ecological
scarcity and in fact in order to to deal
with the problem of of ecological
scarcity we have to face two challenges
a sustainability challenge which
ecological scarcity presents to us and
the funding challenge which is how do we
deal with and overcome global problems
of ecological degradation okay uh why is
ecological scarcity a sustainability
challenge well what we want is economic
development and the reason is that
economic development generates a lot of
benefits including our goals of income
growth employment poverty alleviation
but what should be clear to everyone in
this room given your studies here is
that we have yet to found a way find a
way in which economic development
eliminates completely resource depletion
and pollution the result is we're going
to end up with altered ecosystems and if
we develop in certain ways and we lead
to more resource depletion more
pollution more altered ecosystems we're
going to end up with more ecological
scarcity and the problem is is that so
far we have not convinced global
policymakers the economic development
must take into account the worsening
ecological scarcity that it causes and
that this problem is central to the
sustainable challenge facing the world
today and I'm going to elaborate on this
I'll come back to this in a minute the
second challenge I mentioned is the
funding challenge
basically right now the world faces a
huge gap between the global benefits
that we receive from ecosystems and what
we're willing to pay to maintain and
conserve them as a rough estimate it's
likely that the global benefits of
ecosystems and goods and services are
likely to be in hundreds of billions of
dollars yet at most the world spends
about 10 billion annually on an
ecosystem conservation that's a huge gap
and one area that this is reflected is
in just simple protection which is not
the only aspect of ecosystem
conservation but in terms of the number
of protected areas in the world yes that
continues to grow but they are seriously
underfunded and both globally and
especially in the areas are sorry in the
regions of the world
where the areas of critical diverse
habitats ecosystems and species exist
such as Africa Latin America North
Africa and Middle East in Asia general
tso financing and implementing
international mechanisms to combat this
global funding problem is a critical
challenge facing the world today and
part the second part of the transition
to a green economy all right
I'm now wanting to give a little bit of
context to the sustainability challenge
by talking about sustainable economic
development there's a long history in
the discussion of stainless development
I'm not quite sure how much of this has
been discussed in your classes so bear
with me if this is all hat to you but
this is a perspective that I find
helpful to think about sustainable
development and one not helped to
contribute to you in some of my work
previously it generally and and from a
standpoint of global policymaking it's
been generally accepted that that stable
development the concept starts with the
world come
environment development which defines
sustainable development in 1987 as
development that meets the need of the
present without a compromising the
ability of future generations to meet
their own needs now this definition
since it was formulated by the world
Commission has resonated with economists
because essentially what it tells us is
that future generations should be
entitled to at least the same level of
economic opportunities and thus the same
level of welfare as currently available
to present generations so that's a nice
easy economic goal and target in other
words economic development today must
ensure that future generations are left
no worse off than present generations or
in simple economic terms per capita
welfare should not be declining over
time that it turns helps us think about
how do we provide these economic
opportunities and that in an economic
sense means as long as the total capital
stock of the economy including its
natural capital which determines the
full range of economic opportunities is
available to both present and future
generations then we should be able to
attain sustainable development so if
sustainability is a goal what it means
is that society must decide how best to
use its total capital stock today to
increase current economic activities in
welfare and how much it needs to save or
even accumulate for tomorrow and
ultimately for the well-being of future
generations so already we have got
targets and concepts and it's important
to remember that sustainability is not
the same thing as economic efficiency
economic efficiency as conventionally
divided by economy
is important and necessary condition for
sustainability but it's not sufficient
it's a separate goal to understand that
recall that from your basic economics
training that when we talk about
economic efficiency we're talking about
maximizing the present value of net
benefits resulting from the use of
resources today and in the future that's
an important economic goal economic
efficiency but when we talk about
sustainability we're talking about
something a little bit different an
economy is sustainable when it's on a
time path where future generations have
economic opportunities as least as large
as available to present generations that
depends on time paths of natural
resource capital endowments and
technological progress we can't attain a
sustainable time path without having a
accompanying paths that attain that goal
in terms of our capital stock the result
is that many paths future paths our
economy may be efficient but not all
maybe is sustainable all right how does
this translate into thinking about the
capital needed for our economy well
again let's review how we view capital
in the economy in economics and in our
systems of national counts for our
economy we generally define capital
rather narrowly it's conventionally
defined as reproducible real assets or
physical capital which includes roads
railways buildings private dwellings
factories and so forth and another human
manufactured fixed assets or physical
capital but it's often very clear to us
now that the economy doesn't just depend
on reproducible capital as
conventionally defined
but also human and natural capital in
the last 20 or 30 years in particular
advances in endogenous growth theory in
economics and an empirical growth work
has put emphasis on human capital that
is the education skills and health of
the workforce and the general population
of an economy is an important source of
wealth and I am delighted to say that
natural resource Economist's haven't
contributed as well by identifying
natural capital the economy's endowment
of natural resources such as fossil
fuels minerals arable and grazing land
as well as it's productive biological
resources timber fish and while the
sources and so forth perhaps the newest
contribution is to include or expand
this concept of natural capital to
include ecosystems why would we treat
ecosystems as capital well because just
like any other asset in the economy they
yield a flow of valuable services that
sustain and support economic activity or
as partha descriptor said they are
similar to reproducible capital and they
also can depreciate if misuse are
overused but they are also different
there's problems of irreversibility with
natural capital such as ecosystems or
they at least take a long time to
recover and it's not easy to replace
then once they get degraded and finally
there's problems of collapse
so ecosystems should be treated as a
form of natural capital there are
clearly another asset of the economy but
they're also very different now what
does all this mean for sustainable
development
well let's summarize it in this diagram
here
so sustainable development as defined by
the world commission is development that
meets the needs of the present while not
compromising the ability of future
generations to meet their needs as I've
pointed out in economics that's a very
simple concept it means welfare does not
decline over time and that in turn
requires managing a portfolio of assets
for the economy which doesn't include
just reproducible a fixed capital but
also human capital and now natural
capital which also includes ecosystems
as capital that should be
straightforward right well at this point
I think economists kind of diverge
managing the stock of capital as a
portfolio is fine but we should ask
ourselves are some of this capital
stocks are some of it is some of it
replaceable by other forms of capital or
not
well one can of thinkers on this who had
been identified I didn't choose these
terms but they've been identified as
weak sustainability thinkers argue that
it doesn't matter what goes into our
portfolio of capital assets it could be
less natural capital more human capital
reproducible capital the point is that
the whole portfolio increases in value
imagine you are an investor and you have
a portfolio of stocks in the stock
market it doesn't matter if stock a
declines as long as stocks B and C rise
in value to compensate for the decline
in value of stock a your whole portfolio
value is increasing over time so you're
handing off to your children I'm
wealthier stock of assets which will
give them more wealth for the future
well that's the weak sustainability
argument in a nutshell as long as we can
replace
the capital that we deplete and whatever
form it is with other forms of valuable
capital so the whole value of the
portfolio stock is increasing then we're
gonna make the future better off however
the strong sustainability argument
suggests the problem is that not all
forms of capital in our portfolio for
our economy are equally substitutable
for each other in particular some forms
of natural capital should be kept intact
because there we have not found a way of
substituting for them if we'd lose or
destroy them
once we lose those natural capital it's
irreversible and in any case we don't
really know the value of them we've
never have known the value and we still
don't know the value and we probably
will never guess the future value so the
argument goes is that we can call that
form of a natural capital as essential
natural capital and we should keep it
intact or as much as possible just in a
nutshell the weak versus strong
sustainability argument the weak
sustainability argument is there's no
difference between natural and other
forms of capital and as long as depleted
natural capital is replaced with even
more valuable physical and human capital
then the value of our overall portfolio
is going to increase and what we need to
do to a change and attain sustainability
is to maintain enhance the value of the
aggregate stock the whole portfolio
strong sustainability says we can't view
the whole portfolio as a homogeneous
stock in fact we can't always substitute
for natural capital as uncertainty over
current and future values particularly
avec logical goods and services unique
environments in biodiversity meaning
that some natural capital is always
going to be essential and cannot
be replaced so sustainability requires
maintaining enhancing the the value of
the aggregate capital stock that's true
but it will also require preserving some
essential natural capital now I can go
back to ecological scarcity what this
means is that ecological scarcity is
going to be the KIAC indicator first of
all I think it's clear and certainly
from the quotes I showed you early by
part of the scoop ten others that the
type of natural capital that's gonna
most likely qualify as essential capital
is ecosystems and it's the one that's
particularly at risk there's no argument
about this all the evidence agrees this
but what is what does it mean when we
have rising a colossal scarcity well it
means that we are depleting irrevocably
ecosystems and we're doing this rapidly
so the consequence is is that current
and future generations are going to be
affected our record on this is not very
good the Millennium ecosystem assessment
published in 2005 pointed out that over
the past 50 years ecosystems have been
modified more extensively than in any
considerable period in human history to
the extent that that over sixty percent
of global ecosystem services have been
degraded or used on sustainably and of
course the projections for biodiversity
are even worse we're expecting
biodiversity loss to increase rapidly
over the next 50 years and serious
crises with many species now I think
it's helpful this is a table from which
I included into my paper this is from
the millenia system assessment and you
can see that in the middle column the
type of ecosystem services globally that
are under threat are some very important
services
everything from a key biomass and even
biological resources to freshwater
supplies to increase vulnerability to
pests and to storms and damages so the
services that we're losing are
incredibly important to human welfare
and will increasingly be see it so over
time okay so I just want to summarize so
far so yes we've made some progress in
the last few years towards a green
economy particularly in terms of
jump-starting energy efficiency clean
energy we can argue as to how big those
changes are and how significant they are
but we should at least recognize we've
made a start in those areas at least
compared to five ten years ago but it's
also clear that what's been left out of
the picture is this problem of
ecological degradation which is not
getting better it's getting worse and
it's clearly as I pointed out a key
indicator of the unsustainability of our
current development efforts so basically
what we have is a patterned economic
development not just in one country or a
handful of country but globally that's
in this vicious cycle
and the starting point is increasing
ecologic 'el scarcity and the reason we
have it is that environmental values the
values of these services and goods that
we're losing aren't reflected in current
markets or prices or policies and that
in turn means we're going to continue
pursuing a path of development with
excessive environmental degradation and
as I pointed out in my first figure
that's gonna mean altered ecosystems and
increasing ecological scarcity and as
long as that scarcity isn't appearing
anywhere we're not accounting for it
anywhere the vicious cycle continues and
we're on this path of unsustainability
as defined in terms of compromising the
ability of future generations to meet
their opportunities so we're going to
end up with loss of welfare over time
how do we deal with it well
we have to make some interventions and
the interventions are first of all using
valuation and policy analysis to make
explicit what we're not accounting for
which is the loss of values from
environmental degradation the second we
need to have what I call the five eyes
more in fib a ston the analysis and the
values that we estimate a an
environmental degradation that occurs we
need better information better
incentives institutions investment and
infrastructure to deal with the
excessive environmental degradation and
then finally more ecological and
economic analysis that's in a nutshell
what we need in terms of cooperation
between natural scientists economists
and other social sciences to continue to
analyze the economic and income and
distributional impacts of rising at
collage achill scarcity why isn't this
taking place you know if it's so
straightforward and if many of us have
been talking about this for for twenty
thirty years why why aren't we seeing
more efforts to deal with this well
there has been some progress but the
reason why I think ecological scarcity
has been left out of the equation so far
has to do with transaction costs and in
economics transaction costs are costs
other than market price that are
incurred in existing production and
market relationships so what happens is
that in order to change our existing
market and production relationships to
something else through a policy
intervention we need we would start we
will incur increasing transaction costs
so for example imagine we have a market
transaction
which has a subsidy in it that's
environmentally damaging or it's a it's
a market transaction that imposes an
environmental cost it's an externality
and we want to impose a policy change
well there's a transaction cost even if
the market exists by actually putting in
of these changes and that's area a if we
want to go further and deal with an
underlying market imperfection such as
the lack of property rights or open
access problems then we have to develop
market enabling institutions legal
frameworks perhaps new institutions and
so forth that that enable the market
system to work effectively to overcome
the market failure that underlines the
problem that is area be a bigger
transaction cost and then finally if we
need to go a step further and do
something completely different such as
set up global trading or payments for
echo system services that have never
been set up before we have to set up
treaties international environments
institutional arrangements and legal
systems as well and that's an even
bigger transaction costs which is area C
and unfortunately you can pick your
favorite environmental problem and
you'll have at least one of these
transaction costs area a and probably
all three and the bigger the problem in
terms of scale geographical scale
whether it's a particularly a global
problem as opposed to a local problem
the bigger the transaction costs so
transaction cost is a huge aspect of the
problem and just very briefly one
example I give in my paper about the
transaction costs that you're likely to
see is the example of water markets and
trading one of the most important things
services ecosystems services is the
availability of fresh water and water is
essential to a whole range of economic
active
as well as human livelihoods and health
yet it's probably one of the most
inefficiently manage resources in the
world it's clear that water markets and
trading could be part of the solution to
a lot of water misallocation problems
but as I list here
there are huge transaction costs
encountered for doing that and and
overcoming these transaction costs are
clearly non priced non-market additional
costs that are required and and
necessary to overcome in order to
establish the so it these transaction
cost so there's a huge literature in
economics of water that details these
these types of transaction costs are our
one major reason why we don't see no
more water markets and trading even
though it would lead to more efficient
allocation of water supplies another
reason why we do not see much progress
of improving environmental policy has to
do with what I call either political
costs or vested interests and an example
here is perverse subsidies so as you
well know many more ordinary markets in
agriculture energy water and so forth
there are a lot of subsidies to
producers and to consumers and these
subsidies artificially lowers the cost
of production so for example imagine you
have a market for energy and you have a
subsidy for energy production and the
result is that the costs of supply in
energy goes from s the supply curve s
the supply curve s0 s Prime the result
is an increase in the quantity of energy
supply but as shown in the bottom
diagram there's also an increase in
marginal environmental damage now if we
remove the subsidy it looks like a
win-win subsidies are both in efficient
and environmentally damaging in
markets in the case of energy the fossil
fuel energy they are we know that so if
you remove the subsidy the supply curve
shifts back from s bar to s
environmental damages is reduced so area
D is gained in terms of environmental
gain
there is also an efficiency gain because
you've removed an inefficient pricing
policy which is the subsidy and so
there's an overall gain in efficiency of
C win-win in environmental economics
textbooks that's a win-win sounds good
but here's the problem somebody loses
and who loses is the producer and the
producer surplus lost as you can see in
this diagram is area a plus B so the
political cost of removing environmental
subsidy is area a plus B over area C
plus D and it doesn't matter how big
this relative ratio will be obviously
the bigger it is the more the political
cost is but here's the thing if it's
sufficiently large enough entity loses
out on the political cost they're gonna
make darn sure that it's the removal the
subsidy will not take place despite the
game's overall to society the political
cost of subsidy is worth doing something
about for the cost of subsidy removal is
worth doing something about and the
vested interests will fight it same
thing with the environmental tax we know
that to internalize an externality an
environmental tax can be a very a very
worthwhile objective now obviously if
you impose environmental tax you're
going to raise the cost of supply in
this case from s to s prime by the
amount of the tax
there will be an efficiency loss the
efficiency loss is area c plus d because
you are of course intervening in a
market causing an efficiency loss but
you will also gain in terms of reducing
the
to impact the externality so managing
you imposed a carbon tax on a
competitive energy market fossil fuel
market the carbon tax will cause some
efficiency loss area c plus d but it
will also reduce carbon or greenhouse
gas damages by area e so we could make
the case if the loss in efficiency is
more than compensated by the gains in
reducing environmental damages society
is better off which is why a lot of
economists like using taxes or recommend
using taxes as a way of internalizing
extremely large and damaging
environmental costs as such as
externalities but keep in mind the tax
has another impact which is it's going
to again increase producer losses and
the producer loss is going to be in this
case a plus B plus C so the real
political cost is that area a plus B
plus C over the net gain in from
reducing environmental externalities
hence there's a huge political visted
interest in going against imposing
environmental damages as well okay how
significant is this problem well we know
that environmental asari subsidies are a
huge problem you take four areas major
markets for goods and services in the
world water energy agriculture and
transport and you can see that globally
the subsidies in these markets can be as
close to a trillion dollars based on
available inch estimates now recall what
I said about the global stimulus the
global stimulus packages were about half
fat so if we just cut global subsidies
by one half
we could have financed the entire
- mr. stimulant green stimulus packages
did I mention that occurred but no what
we've done is we've kept the subsidies
going globally and we've added in
additional costs on governments of
funding green stimulus out of out of
expenditures instead
another thing that keep in perspective
global GDP is about twenty five trillion
dollars so this amount is anywhere from
about three to five percent of global
GDP and finally remember what I said
ecosystem conservation ten billion
dollars thousand billion dollars versus
ten ten billion dollars on ecosystem
conservation thousand billion dollars a
trillion dollars on subsidies so I think
the vested argument particularly is
valid also those figures I showed you
are from a range of averages over the
last five to ten years subsidies appear
to be worsening not lessen the vested
interests in those markets are asking
for more not less and it's very clear in
energy subsidies a major report by the
International Energy Agency OPEC even
oacd in the World Bank for the
Pittsburgh g20 summit at the height of
the reception recession estimated the
fossil fuel consumptions subsidies
globally mounted to five hundred fifty
seven billion dollars production
subsidies amounted for another hundred
billion dollars and these together
account for one percent of world GDP in
2008 remember green stimulus amounted to
only 0.7% of GDP on average global GDP
that's just energy not agricultural
water and transport that's just energy
and just for fossil fuel production
consumption is even include nuclear
subsidies not only this report went
further
showed that phasing out these subsidies
by 2020 could result in a 5.8 percent
reduction in global primary energy
demand and a 7 percent fall in
greenhouse gas emissions yet still no
progress has been made all right global
funding provider Essene ecosystems I
mentioned this before about the wide gap
and I think that this gap between
funding global conservation and the
benefits we get really is a reflection
of how far we are from taking
sustainability seriously and there's two
aspects to this funding challenge first
there's the need to design adequate
global mechanisms that provide
compensation for ecosystem services that
have global benefits but are conserved
locally or nationally and secondly we
got to raise and provide adequate
financing of these mechanisms as I
listed in the paper the list of
mechanisms we have available to us
potentially and actually are pretty
interesting pretty significant they
range from what we already have which is
the global environmental facility which
since 1991 over the last 20 years to its
credit has raised over nine billion
dollars for global biodiversity
conservation not bad nine billion
dollars still a poultry some
international payment for ecosystem
services well there's a lot of talk
there is movement and funding for our
EDD our IDI sorry red plus I always get
it wrong reduce emissions from
deforestation and degradation but the
amount of money raised and promise so
far is in the is in the low millions too
early too small billions of dollars not
in the hundreds of billions and that
leads us to other mechanisms
I've already talked about the problems
of raising money through taxes and you
could apply the same arguments to
tradable permits even harder to
instigate because of the transaction
costs and to date the progress on
setting up any kind of global carbon tax
or a global tradable permits system has
has not been very encouraging and that
leaves us with a handful of things that
have been bandied about such as
financial transaction tax or currency
transaction taxes or international
finance facilities such as the one
that's been set up for immunization and
health and then stuff that's been around
for years as far as I can remember such
as taxes on airline travel and arms
trade if you ever done a frequent file
flyer trip to two internationally use
your frequent flyer miles to go
international you'll find out that you
actually say maybe about a third of your
ticket because you still have to pay the
taxes so travel taxes on airline are
already about two-thirds of the cost of
international ticket I'm not sure how
much it can bear and in terms of taxes
on the global arm trade good luck all
right my final remarks is this I've got
nothing against fostering clean energy
and energy efficiency I think it's
necessary it's essential and it's an
important step but it's unlikely to be
sufficient if you're really interested
in a transition to a green economy hard
though it's been and despite the
political backlash we are getting in
many places including this country it is
not sufficient anybody who tells you it
is they're not speaking the truth unless
we deal with ecological scarcity full-on
and it's a global problem that has a
sustainability challenge and a funding
challenge then we're putting the welfare
of future generations and even this
current one at risk I've got four kids
they range in age from 5 to 25
I would like to think that they would
have a better future to me I'm not even
sure I'm gonna have a good future
provided I live that long because of the
rate at which this problem is getting
worse and accelerating if there if
global policymakers are truly willing to
break the vicious cycle of unsustainable
development then we've got to address
the current global shortfall an
ecosystem conservation I think many
countries could raise the money through
their own national needs particularly
the more rich and rapidly developing and
industrializing countries but there's
many other countries of the world in
many other regions within countries of
the world which desperately need
assistance and we're talking about
global benefits here benefits today and
in the future we have to deal with it
I think potential biggest breakthrough
and hope might be through a currency
transaction tax or financial transaction
tax I talk about that in my paper and I
actually think perversely the time to do
it is now because as Stephanie Griffiths
Jones argued improving the net
contribution of the financial sector to
the real economy and to the welfare of
ordinary people would significantly
rehabilitate the financial sectors
battered image which should be a
desirable aim of that sector itself so I
think there is some hope there I don't
hold up much hope for those other global
funding mechanisms I have some hope
there it's a modest hope but hopefully
we'll go from there thanks very much
you